You know, appreciate you. I mean, whatever, it's all good, but
I don't know, man. We're flying by the seat of our pants.
I've been looking at these workout videos. Cause I work out now by in my garage,
I kind of go to the gym and I just kind of do my workouts.
And I noticed men's health asked me if I wanted to do one of their, uh,
workout videos and men's health. And I was like, yes, sign me up.
And then I was like, wait a minute. How do I do it though? Because uh,
the camera crew is we can't do it at my gym because of the Corona virus.
I was like, did they just does a camera crew corner, my house.
And we're working on like a Raj. And they were like, no,
you'd shoot it yourself and send it to them and they'll cut it together.
And I go like this, bye. I gotta do it.
My self dude. So I've been looking at these videos.
I love the videos. I think the men's health put together some cool.
And then I went into other videos that were like less professional.
And why don't any of these Marvel actors or jurors that
are getting jacked for movies? The, whether it be the rock or anybody,
the videos should just be here's how fun getting the rockets jacked.
Here's how Hugh Jackman got jacked for Logan.
And then a guy comes on and he's like, hi,
this is how Hugh Jackman got jacked for Logan. Right? Dan on
rent. [inaudible] we're just doing,
doing freeze frame, bicep, curls, Daniel
[inaudible] bedrest.
[inaudible] pimp. They use steroids.
That's why they look like a painting, bro.
I work out so hard and your boy eats every now and then slipped up a little bit
tonight, ate some eggplant Parmesan, but it was yummy. And bro,
I work out hard as. Dude. I go hard.
I keep my brow furrowed and I'm always in keypad DACI and that means horse
stance in Japanese dude. I'm multicultural. And so I do that and I'm sweating.
Hey, your boy's got some. He's not looking like the rock.
You boys. Not looking like Hugh Jackman in, in, uh, Logan,
your boys not looking like Chris Evans in captain America. Okay.
Or even Chris Pratt in guardians of the galaxy. Do you know why?
Cause they're cycling. They're using roids,
dude. Why is that? Not something. Why are there even making those videos? Well,
here's what a lot to do. Huge acquisition is what a lot to do. You know? I go,
Hey, I do dead lifts.
And then I run on the treadmill for an hour and then I'll do dead lifts and then
I'll do more dead lifts. And then I do, uh,
I'll do like a chest exercises, trainees, bald.
And he's not even really he's a lot of he's got fit. The trainers that they got,
they're always like fat a little bit. He's fed he's Bolden. He's fat,
but he's more training. Thanks to him. Thanks to him out we air.
And there was something else I was forgetting also thanks to Steve
gain. And [inaudible] Dan [inaudible] Jean
[inaudible]
and, and guess what though, dude, and I'm telling you right now,
this ain't. I'm doing a movie.
It's not in the foreseeable future yet,
but dude say I won't be in an action movie. First of all,
I got one coming out called army, the dead, your boy
your boy w where are you going? Where are you going? That's me?
Where are you going? That's me bro. You saying I don't look legit where you go,
Oh, put that down, put that down, put that down.
Okay. That's your boy. And I'm all geared up from the feet up.
I got full of clothes on because I play a helicopter pilot.
So I'm in natural movie coming out, whether you like it or not. Okay.
When I really get the,
when I'm really with the dude,
when your boys sliding over car roofs on his and the
jackets picking out the back.
When your boys got one gun in one hand and the other hands loosey
goosey. Cause he needs to slide over the hood of the car with the jacket,
picking out the back. Say,
I won't say I won't walk, slow motion, waltz,
our car explodes in the background. Say, I won't not look back.
Say I won't not look back. Your boy will do it.
And when your boy does it
and when your boy works out real hard for that role,
your boy is also going to be doing steroids.
And that's no joke. And I can't wait until somebody says,
so how'd you get fit? You know, as of Jay Leno is still a thing.
So how do you get a fan for the wrong, you know, steroids, Jay
Dan it welcome, man. Thank you for that tonight.
Show Dan on an on ramp. Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam. You flexing the mirror.
latch, looking like a turtle rent Dan and then renter then zooming in a,
the whole movie was shot on my back, but then they ran Pam. Pam.
Oh, suicide is painless.
It's not, you know it is maybe if you
it, dude. That's the, man. When your boys really with the,
I'm doing steroids. When the goes down,
I don't give a gap to the bald is jacked,
like a turtle and moving slow too. Cause my joints hurt.
Okay.
Yeah. Do it. I will do steroids. Can't wait. Just getting so mad at my girl.
Where's the chicken. Where's the chicken.
I got to eat the chicken. Now I got to eat after I work out. I gotta get it.
Now. She's like, what's wrong? Just seeing,
seeing the back of my throat with my teeth closed because the gap is so big.
You could buy a cable knit sweater in it. it. Do it. I'm doing it all.
Oh winner.
I'm a winner. And you are too dude.
That's what this podcast is about coming together.
This is a cult coming together in this cult.
And when I take steroids, I'm being honest with you, babies. I haven't yet.
I haven't even taken whatever they call it. Any kind of thing.
Some guy came up to those. Jamie, are you taking two years of testosterone?
Your boy goes all natural man. And it's hard.
But when that movie comes along, well, they want you to I'll take steroids.
Don't worry. And gang gang, gang gang. If you'd like to make a call,
please hang up. Oh, Perrier,
make bigger cans, dude. What is this? A penis dude.
That's how big my penis is. I swear to God. Um, yeah bro.
You know, I gotta start doing anyway, dude, that the workout celeb,
the videos are hilarious. We do six sets of
chin ups and then six sets of the things. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, cool.
And then you shoot up in your. Anyway.
Watch my Netflix special.